chino ordenado el cierre de una zona de
genyou la capital provincial de General
donde está ubicada la mayor fábrica de
iphones del mundo pertenece a la
multinacional taiwanesa foxcon
responsable del 70% de los iphones
globales y la mayor parte salen de esta
fábrica con 200.000 trabajadores así que
es más que probable que el suministro
global quede afectado en los próximos
meses el parón además llega en el peor
momento antes de las vacaciones y cuando
la producción debería alcanzar sus
máximas cotas foxcom ha desviado parte
de la producción a otras plantas pero
los expertos opinan que se verá
recortada al menos en un 30%, yenyou ha
lidiado con un brote de Kobe durante las
últimas semanas y los problemas llegaron
a la fábrica en los últimos días cuando
se obligó a los trabajadores a comer en
los dormitorios muchos temieron un
confinamiento inmediato y salieron a la
carrera de la fábrica algunos saltando
la valla y Caminando por la carretera
con sus maletas en unas imágenes que se
hicieron virales en un momento china
sigue fiel a la política de Cero covid y
este fin de semana decenas de miles de
visitantes del parque Disneylandia de
Shanghai fueron retenidos durante horas
y solo pudieron salir con el resultado
negativo de una prueba pcr que se les
había practicado en las mismas
instalaciones